a cat rabbit it's your point cycle
[ __ ] babble okay what day is it
there's daddy we're going to play some
more games you know that's that's what
we do on the second channel would play
some [ __ ] games matrix in this water
don't play this game called Emily's
[ __ ] away too you know so this is the
way you first see when you [ __ ] open
up this game I can't picture so let's
tear that so do this now choose your
desktop background back in election not
up yeah cerulean and more of a [ __ ]
however like a sounds of this game was
shut
yeah well this is I steal your personal
information I was [ __ ] so really and
exploit it please set this your back in
now okay but what is it oh [ __ ] it Emily
tell okay chapter one but Flynn settings
and this is I can launch yeah baby
that's what I'm talking about my little
[ __ ] that's what I'm talking about
okay yep sick new chapters summer 2006 -
Emily hell yeah [ __ ] them only like
mother what's a choose everybody I think
every boy a better person that anyone
has ever loved Michael cross okay [ __ ]
try got shoes okay but there's the
August therapy for senior year okay high
school yeah [ __ ] that noise and XII
[ __ ] [ __ ] Oh
my name is deep boy 69 okay my name I'm
socket Bret
okay yeah people walking outside okay
get my profile
ha the 70 showing Sims 2 I'm a [ __ ]
Sims player personal profile
Chamillionaire they see me room and
really he in a mess hat okay yeah
Brett yo [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
going out [ __ ] the [ __ ] I just hit yo oh
I had to [ __ ] it tight y'all know what's
up I gotta just chill a [ __ ]
now you to a [ __ ] now she's [ __ ]
that just you what about the paint my
nails [ __ ]
and I'll pigeon else can decide what
color though a [ __ ] black my looks
like a little [ __ ] black as nice
black as my [ __ ] on a moonless night
inside of a coffin
okay a black is that even a question
what does this do what is this that's
different kind of great a suite of
colors I like your new scheme hex bro
hey what it was buddy for a while how do
you [ __ ] him like Auto type type assist
is on there we go
[Music]
thanks bro sad you're so good at
breaking Brian but touching some dick
touching some taps you know what I'm
saying is pretty good up on forever
that's how woody went up to that [ __ ]
hang out with Fred right now video game
[ __ ] speaking up I should [ __ ]
change my [ __ ] picture
oh [ __ ] sleep oh so parties that sort of
[ __ ] you know baby yeah deep boy I can't
believe a cool on a month yeah I want to
go back okay yeah better me yeah that
right yeah I can't really back because
you're smart you're a stud yeah Lister
pays the best bro actually get rid of
this [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm not going to ask about her I know
funny how we never like talk before you
still have to hang out with me my
friends sometime yeah definitely batch
snappy awesome
what the [ __ ] set background gotta be
quieter summer and Ryan out you know
trying to get my tip wet you know Holly
asked about her Jesus jumping up the
Warped torn Sunday God tomash come on
baby
oh yeah a lot punk rock show so you can
wash my puppet what's your favorite kind
of music
Oh [ __ ] it I like it [ __ ] on my hip
hop below [ __ ] hip hop for sure [ __ ]
[Music]
my favorites change everything I'm just
uh cool got to go in the brat you're
[ __ ] go to with a lady can't wait to
see it says the scales you know the
[ __ ] cars we're gonna [ __ ] doesn't
knows how to spell and I a [ __ ] like
ok ok here we go here we go welcome out
to my poverty have you heard this one
[Music]
ok ah
you can give this music it's like a fake
youth to bestest pops up with the
address emily is away calm you see if I
can switch it real quick
[Music]
Game Capture
so
everything
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you [ __ ] it okay well I guess
I'd like that
yes here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
get the cash
I don't know why it's like that this is
so weird
okay [ __ ] that
cuz this yeah you sure you want to
remote okay yeah this is great
[ __ ] everything went to say it would say
is great because I'm trying to smash
some decks tonight yeah yeah the best
it's official oh [ __ ] I should [ __ ]
look at mine should we room edit profile
edit profile what the [ __ ] is this
sure it's a raisin yeah you trying to
get in his pants but no [ __ ] cuz I'm
just up for asking okay see if I could
[ __ ] move
this I want to move this out here so you
actually see what's going on because the
other things just okay uh tip that
tickets total y'all have to text my
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] she like that he's [ __ ]
dripping wet she's sure everything what
I could tell you probably like that
column it's kind of a dick move and I
laid that betcha I'll Bend I'm gonna get
in this bitch's passed so fast she's
gonna be screaming
[Music]
what am I being a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
how do you got back ah [ __ ] it
I guess by every Jack is that yes the
Pope yeah lol sure you I got a plague
got a bike gotta play cool you know why
the [ __ ] it gotta play [ __ ] cool oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] the descent [ __ ]
little sock that aren't even a [ __ ]
choice just like us but I can but that's
okay because that's where they got it
[ __ ] the [ __ ] at anyone's do it
all that well [ __ ] [ __ ] all the way
horror worth it at pusher bra just got a
text
how's your head then out that
[ __ ] thought [ __ ] come on back
ma zhanlin hey Bret how they help
[ __ ] la with a bang your [ __ ]
brains out I just chillin what the
[ __ ] up with you
[Music]
do I know him can I hang out with
friends [ __ ] I hung out a friend
all right
not only 20 but he got a fake ID I bet
that had oh you like that I need to get
a friend get one I fought with one
till my watch and oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
I did some jackass stunts my name is
dick boys 69
[Music]
Wow they ended up with a lot I see some
drunk text and let me through oh my god
I'll give them your screen name
there we go that's hilarious
that's hilarious even though this lady
has no sense of humor
okay how does it matter really had two
[ __ ] in my pants I'm gonna get two
[ __ ] United Oh what why
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh am I like video games [ __ ] I don't
know you're plague [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Bay Bay Bay Bay Bay Bay say my tongue so
misbehaves Snow Patrol Arctic Monkeys
that moves pretty fast I was it okay I
just let you apply brakes ourselves uh
yeah I just rest
sorry I'm [ __ ] Am I
[Music]
pretty solid choice for the [ __ ] man I
should I go for both of at the same time
no I got a bag this [ __ ] it out like
[Music]
yeah but like deleting typing typing up
course I [ __ ]
should I get punk girl look Emily now
punk girls kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] show okay
[ __ ] her [ __ ] her hey I know that's okay
I would like sure I like RPGs - oh [ __ ]
we'll look like I'm gonna get this tip
with ya big hop out an eyepatch
ah good friends get we shout that we're
[ __ ] show okay I'm switching my [ __ ]
how do I add at this against me should
tie a night oh [ __ ] something's before
[Music]
does it fail
that's cool I'm going to the secret is a
never if Mac asked I'm glad your last
time I never asked with a boyfriend just
pretend you're gonna give a [ __ ] oh
whatever
Amar's man I hope you got no cause after
the shopping yeah Internet and I can't
[ __ ] okay what were you thinking
about contraceptives H oh don't ask me
how up for a play yeah yeah like hell
like hell
[Music]
now you say of course say this you don't
want to like push anything you don't
want to say no you want to like say like
yeah let's be friends like you know like
chasing cars
what about [ __ ] nothing right you know
you know no you say yes would be friends
also you mind if I invite my other
friends to dinner and your other friend
is your dick with a bow tie on it okay
let's see this come on come on Snow
Patrol
[Music]
7/7 bad bad bad bad bad bad damper Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam okay yeah bad yeah I
liked us
yes [ __ ] oh oh that's not so good time
to change my [ __ ] profile my monkey
facial Renetta doll be normal there we
go mmm-hmm I'm surreal worship actually
good gorgeous you know what else has got
a generator that's all Charo MLA oh good
but I'm [ __ ] yeah some friends cowbells
oh [ __ ]
I'm going to hip hop I can't lie
she's alternative everyone knows that
come on I'll turn them
[Music]
if ya like a bat
[Music]
come on huh
there where they got oh my god this girl
is probably already pregnant we're just
talking to me
oh hey can I have that
oh my god emily is going to get ahead
dick suck your dog ate it
[Music]
come on
what is it let's say come on mother get
this girl's tip wet oh I hate drinking
hey King
Emily you know what's really fun
strawberry flavor a slipper kick yeah
nada
[Music]
Emily I hope you ain't no Catholic girl
dad you sound like band track you know
yeah neutral like you're dead inside
[Music]
they all scheduling complex
[Music]
get away happened oh yeah
[Music]
and I pay pops slack okay there's only
one hole in the body not seven
now what the [ __ ] I said now now you
know where to find my batch
[Music]
stay up fetch some 5-hour energy she's
not gonna like this
Shay is not gonna like this [ __ ] what a
[ __ ] horrible ending okay if there's
no love in the world
we'll make a no world and we'll give it
some walls and a knocker that resonates
so software that will never hear it
Jodie Foster senior year okay it's been
like for like a year later all right so
this is where I start treating Emily
even better in treating a but like chef
okay
mmm [ __ ] thank you liar scrubs FMO
scrubs about why this is a boat no smell
at all Borat the best is yet to come
it's a Geisha personalized yeah my
homegirl see her Ross holy [ __ ]
okay holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] happen to
her anything happening here
[Music]
if you went to that one listen to some
music I'm good
[ __ ] forget come on Emily I know you're
there [ __ ] what's her birthday Halloween
she liked that she liked that she'll
like if I went out councilís okay Bob
for apples see I just liked you some
light-hearted joking around with her you
know boss some apple maybe play some
games I'm so happy it's fallen take my
favorite saison oh yeah that's Frank Oz
oh look here's a pessimist at heart
come on [ __ ] huh
thought about it just very very handsome
distance yourself just listen to
yourself
rock rock run away jack is having a big
party I'm looking at costumes now what
anything I should go as Alice in
Wonderland [ __ ] it's exactly
what she doesn't want
get up it's gonna be a bad choice
exactly exactly you're gonna kill us
I'll show you this take this balloon
yeah what the [ __ ] is wrong with this
[ __ ] Sallie actually you know this
[ __ ] like Sally better come on [ __ ]
come on
okay that's fine yeah [ __ ] mask on
yourself out [ __ ] okay oh my god what
is wrong with if you like entourage like
this place of work and okay
[Music]
there you go I know [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah like Genco oh it's kind of really
drive our panties okay I'm at it smart
[Music]
yeah thanks oh Jesus she's like [ __ ]
what my bag
that's right I'm [ __ ] busy uh head on
oh yeah okay I'm waiting for I want to
get back come on
okay I punk ah
what is with her giving out my [ __ ] um
uh wait should I
[Music]
the [ __ ] is this okay I'll just I can
get this in here there we go okay you
guys see this
okay email yes screen in yes female 99
[Music]
single men Chanel throw shopping a
lecher how Halloween party you to change
your own picture Jackie stay friends
swag a minute this horse is a [ __ ]
train wreck okay
[Music]
thank a listening to news that I'm not
gonna kind of like this [ __ ] [ __ ]
she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Sue's us and I got come on and I where I
am are you come on ah it's all the good
and all second Samuel come down here I
can [ __ ] that [ __ ] second trash and
awesomesauce I'm glad you like the same
music it's me oh thanks okay man Kenny
let's continue continue
I'm glad we're friends there we go I
just [ __ ] broke our panties yeah yes
sure like a lot that I have people
chains in my basement
[Music]
I'm she's gonna [ __ ] frat me
ah ah sounds fun okay okay just ask ask
we'll come to mind first if you take too
long
it'll just be my turn again [ __ ] born
ready
come on come on
do you mind my favorite kind of movie a
fox you like heart right quick ask me
anything uh favorite animal a really
cool question it's like one's question
for you look of a shed about trying hard
cats have you ever snuck out of her
house no he's a good boy well I'm so not
her type but she really want some beers
like have you ever done any drugs mr
Evelyn I know she has I don't even know
why I'm asking um I don't know yet and
then get the [ __ ] away from me
[Music]
ever had your hard work
good good yes about you I'm asking two
questions I'm Perry okay let's say you
yes yes come on come on
[Music]
okay this is a toxic one good and now
I'm excited half like you are our train
wreck of a birthday it's a fake ID guy
yeah they good your sex really care
[Music]
now that sounds pretty complicated
sharing plan I messed up okay that's
that's fine as in here in college
[ __ ] make them like understand what a
good she is okay son
[Music]
okay dinner okay and didn't really want
to ask those questions but I guess I'm
[ __ ] force I would [ __ ] if this is
real life I'll trade something I'll be
like yeah get out of here okay how are
you come on this girl's killing me
[Music]
hey yeah what is I really don't want to
know I don't anything aunty don't want
to dogs with birthing I like half of my
away myself I was like now okay with him
[ __ ] now see how do you [ __ ] this
time
[Music]
okay now I haven't that's a [ __ ] lie
that's a [ __ ] lie but I am gonna say
no thanks oh I'm just sayin I get a sex
I know em er didn't have sex before she
is to pee or honey I'm a minute sure
this lady it just like needs like out
flowers okay like why telling me not
judgement we gonna get married oh my god
she's [ __ ] getting Felix to make come
on I like come on I like comeback
[Music]
if there's anything I learned at school
it's never ask open-ended questions okay
okay cut what I believe is girls kill me
come on [ __ ] come on
[Music]
yeah have so much time
[Music]
I said you're a lying [ __ ] so I have
[ __ ] cow flour in this game [ __ ]
counselor this second and no problem yes
I thought sure how can I give me a
family why not yeah Shannon says Kelly
jesus [ __ ] Heather makes all her
problems
yeah why's MLA pleased last one
fuckin'-a Jesus come on we work by such
friends
oh [ __ ] it egg just like a dick and go
home great yes we are great friends we
are great friends are you tired
[ __ ] [ __ ] that one up
[Music]
nao Henry I lost
hey come on juice okay I can't come come
on Emily conquered
that's okay real-deal guys really Red
Alert
you gotta hate that chest yeah I got a
hint that time I get engaged now
oh yeah job
[Music]
don't get any wrong match
[Music]
and I am tucking the bread the coolest
kid on Al
so we're that [ __ ] [ __ ] hey well
same same time Emma's a Mariners at the
face it's okay high school inna in a
relationship
holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] him out
break that [ __ ] in half
Jeff and a friend he's talking to some
pretty alright [ __ ]
so she'll get to it tennis you see here
okay nice status MLA like you wear the
coolest [ __ ] so I can do it and I'm just
[ __ ] sent a friend request
[Music]
what the [ __ ] it's a radio that I have
to be selling that batch mmm Emily am I
am I am really what am I gonna do
[Music]
man yes I'm going to chat like
[ __ ]
[Music]
sure thing except a mile I'm right about
this okay great
[ __ ]
where is it can you link it [ __ ] I look
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't do it
like it I look like a dick it'll click a
dick oh here we go okay
[ __ ] hey my radio so much coming over
and I've got a little homework to do
what holy [ __ ]
man what a dick okay definitely not this
guy's [ __ ] crazy
[Music]
and back up
[Music]
away messages or the best 2006 a little
funky right there little um years ago a
spy
[Music]
yes [ __ ] I our PJs share the same was
the same please don't [ __ ] mmm-hmm
deep voice sixteen bad come on come on
[Music]
- full out okay it's going to take like
ten years oh wow dude Wow okay
[Music]
they're from eyes let it go now yeah
thanks for chef Danielle oh man I'm
gonna pillage a town okay jam radio Oh
[ __ ] loves from use holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] anywhere I don't know what this
[ __ ] want in a room huh
[Music]
after the same well sorry hit the mic
[Music]
come on mo
[Music]
[Music]
and yeah and I kind of get important
that lease not crazy like [ __ ] high
by capital a not are you crazy
like [ __ ] it Diana Evelyn I know
[Music]
[Music]
whole let's now this betcha wall okay
[Music]
do you like this batch oh yeah come on
immerse she doesn't want to be more
serious come on come on come on okay
okay
[Music]
don't sew it so I'm happy I don't catch
it okay Kalibak online
[Music]
yeah yeah
presently the cold [ __ ] do whatever
everyone every Brett
[Music]
it's a drowning man I hide out yo man
over that mat my hello [ __ ] your [ __ ]
brains out okay
I got like pretty soon unless it was
going to trick just wear them all right
Laura [ __ ]
[Music]
ooh that was a trap but I just [ __ ]
dodged no no no no no keep the [ __ ] out
of here right back our [ __ ] out all
right back I shut up
great oh great oh great [ __ ] [ __ ] now
that that
[Music]
now you look [ __ ] I get got either got
it boy 69 Yo Ma
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] weird all right no [ __ ] hard
iron too hard for you and baby yeah bad
time
[Music]
[Music]
no worries bro oh yeah oh oh you like it
hot you're like a tell me your heart
doesn't raise for hurricane a burning
building i brothers that terrified and
live forever
oh so this is [ __ ] I want stronger
just once she's ahead
hmm
what would she like she would not like
fall boys shoulder Manju now maybe she
liked Mika okay hold on
pincers to Orchestra holy [ __ ] okay how
do I get to mine again how do I get to
mine again
there you go [ __ ] ignore your fish
[Music]
yeah of course hello Pepe
I'm brat in that grinning second [ __ ]
the right JumpShip red how much [ __ ]
would you have to so cool please master
shorter
okay everywhere I see X now [ __ ] I
for you I [ __ ] love Chanel I'm Zack
[Music]
[Music]
already went up to this batch
[Music]
[Music]
wait really I squash my tractor
[Music]
[Music]
ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
this [ __ ] [ __ ] shut up I'm gonna [ __ ]
a psychopath okay so I'll read Enoch
fetch the night we've done let's see
okay you're crazy [ __ ] show
[Music]
I want to join simply [ __ ] yeah that's
compare use option come on what are we
celebrating bench no no what the [ __ ]
and where's MA of course
ma ma would it be wrong with you if
every [ __ ] time we're [ __ ] with the
as hat right now
[Music]
[Music]
yes Jeff I don't like a break-off bench
break a bat batch come on bring it
[Music]
let's go surf with that [ __ ]
come on ours oh yeah well you say come
on come on what'd you say [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah Here I am
[Music]
I'm up yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
go on oh boy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fucking-a we all that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
day
[Music]
come on yeah
[Music]
[Music]
that sucks my fresh don't worry that
your psychobabble here
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
car knows what's going on okay I've got
a lot and then white bun knife throat
hey what's going on
[Music]
what's that help
[Music]
that's inside how can I come on batch
[Music]
Sharon Xin guy so so I can get rid Jeff
[Music]
[Music]
come back
[Music]
and this [ __ ] is crazy tell us my love
break-up of them
[Music]
[Music]
Emmer's Emmer's killa very mi o mas
moistening hot for now okay well here's
a point wait tell his mouth and you're
[ __ ] cut that cord ton I need to tell
someone
Kyle's mother tell us [ __ ] mother
[Music]
there we go we got this batch don't
break up with that [ __ ]
[Music]
oof
ooh not sorry
good good
[Music]
and not have to [ __ ] matter wait go
okay that way got backup contact my
batch yeah it's either the breaks up
through fire you killed myself
[Music]
game is that static oh that's why I
can't come on come on yeah come on girl
come on girl like that gasps sick person
odd friend
[Music]
[Music]
yes that way come on cake come with
comments yes keep going keep going with
it deep boy 69 you go and do I think
we're more than friends but it's a
little dated
come on okay come on come on baby
oh is it a name
woo clencher oh oh oh my god okay she
let me ship in Park Heights had been a
[Music]
ok
[Music]
yes glaze ooh we are getting man okay
like carefully I can only get so erect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
Oh mommy like a mommy like a okay so
that was December that was 2007 what if
you lose like a you or me it's always
yourself through fantasy Emily's face
Mac okay that's [ __ ] cop
[Music]
let's do this [ __ ] let's get a little
dirty [ __ ] Oh
okay fire fuzz all right go go Arctic
Monkeys holy [ __ ]
Oh shet miss lady em just say Anna Anna
whatever but she like that nice now [ __ ]
happen to her but you have to do five
fetch something as psychedelic
[Music]
yeah that's grant fetch you say Jeff
will [ __ ] Chihuahua
I got one
I know let's go of my brow I think the
lot of choice is going mad exit for the
end okay I'm mad at that justice
Jeff dead right
[Music]
[Music]
let's see what the [ __ ] is it so Snow
Patrol I guess it's kind of like eff up
[Music]
come on come on Emily go [ __ ] Kelly cow
spells she alive go to prom holy [ __ ]
heck I've got Matt so I guess I'm going
to prom with him
[Music]
Academy just so I got a [ __ ] TV today
okay okay let's kind of go okay oh [ __ ]
oh yeah bye ready come on baby come on
oh my god okay so this is good maybe
they can stain or something
[Music]
[Music]
everything's good where I'm sailing oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] great this [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
there's people walking around outside
the [ __ ] it no jobs
now you better pick I believe in you
[Music]
[ __ ] blow yeah I think as we're dead oh
holy [ __ ]
I'm gonna get those [ __ ] panties off
if intimate butter that's to jet go to
school or friend's party
ah
school's out for place that safe bet or
hello you lose your bet come on Ben
okay I have fun I'm just out gotta be
[Music]
safe okay I think count that's where on
the whole [ __ ] stretch I love event
[Music]
we've got got very good did you did a
fact that I could not sure I really
should call our [ __ ]
[Music]
what happened now oh my god wait cold
self that we saved like I should know
this okay
[Music]
I thought I can have that I'll [ __ ] a
couple so yeah now I found the same
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
oh god sighs better myself that well I
wouldn't really say that take bring a
battle from the enemy okay so good
very exciting all right okay okay how do
we [ __ ] get so desktop okay dr. Jose
okay
[Music]
what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] how do I
oh [ __ ] all right I'm really afraid to
press this I hope it doesn't sign me out
[ __ ]
I'm so good [ __ ] come on and away me
[Music]
okay
I'm holy [ __ ]
no no no no wait
[Music]
how so [ __ ] deuces
[Music]
okay [ __ ] I can't just go on I have to
[ __ ] talk to that fish gallery and I
check this [ __ ] desktop okay [ __ ] I
got took a psycho [ __ ]
all right now [ __ ] hey at msan I should
only talk about of grouse I yeah
[Music]
whatever
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] a less than yes
better bring it okay alright I know you
shot some fun just comes back
[Music]
someone needed me and I chose her over
you Evelyn I chose and definitely not
the case
this [ __ ] crying [ __ ] [ __ ] up my
[ __ ] now she's done she's done okay
Congrats Congrats buddy and brother
those lat yeah it's just you're a psycho
come on I'm on slide eight o'clock like
look at torture talking [ __ ] torture
pocket I would match Anna I play myself
a kadala day when I'm talking to you
[ __ ] what Sam so what what Janice and
I am that well there you're gonna have
to come on come on
[Music]
yeah yeah okay so it's getting dark
Jackie come on so [ __ ] [ __ ] down then
we start okay fish lot a [ __ ] is the
aniline if it's my Hebrew name this
particular trying to fight [ __ ] oh my
god okay okay okay
they should shave the best okay yes yes
yes I've got more the contestants here
I'm lucky
[Music]
did you get it [ __ ] mine and what do
I [ __ ] psychopath [ __ ] [ __ ]
trying so [ __ ] hard to [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and I will not allow I will not allow it
okay it's very nice yeah yeah [ __ ]
boy I should take like 10 hours yeah
you're gonna like a rabble
[Music]
[Music]
ah I got out on Shane [ __ ] you can just
look at yourself
[ __ ] get in light and I watch a net
paste second [ __ ] okay guys get the
[ __ ] out of here this is the end
chapter 5 okay chapter icons
okay so this is like the end the summer
I've seen years of [ __ ] [ __ ] is going
crazy
superior broad College - mouse you say
what her thing I'm wearing
you
[ __ ] once and hey [ __ ] to you what's
wrong with this [ __ ] isn't safe yeah
Cory it's your [ __ ] trouble okay man
right this could be [ __ ] up Khan
[Music]
what's up [ __ ] the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
okay at the next full bath exhausting a
conversation
[Music]
okay okay hey [ __ ] [ __ ] damage
control what is it what is it come on
fix this [ __ ]
take it side
[Music]
okay second try Oh half a about a I'm
here FEA what what ah
[Music]
Evelynn call me ace crazy just crazy
[Music]
[Music]
have we used to be like way back come on
like look what don't drink at it Oh
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay [ __ ] forever
okay we'll fix that [ __ ] Emily's a
little much that's not what's going on
okay when we were going to say she wants
to go a little crazy and run away so be
it but chef I'm the same as before
[Music]
old shits prints crazy just suck it up
[Music]
[Music]
now of course not YHA
it's not catch me I'll just try my drill
back okay
[Music]
[Music]
like I want to impress her now it's what
she wanted there we go area of fun not
saying it's my perspective it was not
that bad it was nothing but a good
coffee for this yes I think it's nothing
I would never and never manipulated you
I have never and would never manipulate
you why would I lie why would you lie
about that
[Music]
I don't like okay that family see it's
not shet this game really gets you sir
perfect answer everything looks like I
was getting well crazy I guess someone's
on her dare like no I'm not lying I'm
not having anything that's the show
penne
mmm was gonna be crazy I bet she could
be some of craziness tomorrow just like
a batch
[Music]
because how much I care about you guys
thank you
I would drink their bathwater baby okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
oh yeah say her name
sigh hurt I have a time ago miss you
baby
[Music]
[Music]
ah smells of time they've always thanked
class Stefan I glad we won
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes I can fix this [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] she lino
[Music]
[Music]
shut up gone pro there we go that way I
got that
[Music]
[ __ ] still have that ticket if he does
have that sake I can't tell these it
really doesn't out but he does that's
like Goldman yes a very good thing why
are you crying that we were so perfect
and what a lot can't [ __ ] a [ __ ]
high school grounds
our feelings are real our feelings are
real long like a breath what hey just a
lot where does that leave us
[Music]
right that's okay I got a couch
[Music]
[Music]
it's not like that
[ __ ] them have on notice that my side
[Music]
[ __ ] love life
[Music]
second Wow Wow okay I need some with a
go candy it's like a [ __ ] brain okay
I needed a sit with a brain is this her
oh yeah I should play victim that I
shall play Becca oh yeah you [ __ ] to
shoot that coming up she spoke coming Co
and I'm not really maybe never
[Music]
perfect perfect second bedroom
[Music]
okay I'll break it up
[Music]
[Music]
I live seok-ki boys 69 throw it into it
go back stops and have a seven-step it
felt it felt like a breakup [ __ ]
sense
oh [ __ ] what a [ __ ] what a complete
[ __ ] what this [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] leave Britney Alone
chef Evelynn achoo
we got em ours though that really gets
Facebook
brother
[Music]
flag is a concert applying an offensive
okay well anyways it's been a put a fun
time thanks our plan y'all emily is a
[ __ ]
apples a [ __ ] and this just goes to
show that you love that room okay thank
you